we are asked what is the distance
between the following points so pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out
well there's multiple ways to think
about it the way I think about it is
really to try to draw a right triangle
where these points where the line that
connects these points is the hypotenuse
and then we can just use the Pythagorean
theorem let me show want to show you
what I am talking about so let me draw a
right triangle here so that is the
height of my right triangle and this is
the width of my right triangle and then
the hypotenuse will connect these two
points I could use my little ruler tool
here to connect that point and that
point right over there I'll color it in
orange so there you have it and so there
you have it I have a right triangle
where the line that connects those two
points is the hypotenuse of that right
triangle now why is that useful from
this can you pause the video and figure
out the length of that orange line which
is the distance between those two points
well what is the length of this red line
well you could see it on this grid here
this is equal to 2 it's exactly 2 spaces
and you can even think about it in terms
of coordinates the coordinate of this
point up here is negative 5 comma 8
negative 5 comma 8 the coordinate here
is X is 4 y 6 4 comma 6 and so the
coordinate over here is going to have
the same the same y-coordinate is this
point so it's going to be comma 6 it's
going to have the same x-coordinate as
this point so it's going to be negative
5 comma 6 and so notice you have a
you're only changing in the y-direction
and you're changing by 2 now what's the
length of this line well you could count
it out 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so it's 9 or
you could even say hey look we're only
changing our in the x-value we're going
from negative 5 x equals negative 5 to x
equals 4 so we're going to increase by 9
now all of that just sets us up so that
we can use the
doreen theorem if we call this C well we
know that a squared plus B squared is
equal to C squared or we could say that
two squares let me do it over here to
use the same red color 2 squared plus 9
squared plus 9 squared is going to be
equal to our hypotenuse squared which
I'm just calling C is going to be equal
to C squared which is really the
distance that's what we're trying to
figure out so 2 squared that is 4 plus 9
squared is 81 that's going to be equal
to C squared and so we get C squared is
equal to 85 C squared is equal to 85 or
C is equal to the principal root of 85
now can I simplify that a bit let's see
how many times does 5 go into 85 it goes
let's see it goes 17 times so neither of
those are perfect squares yeah that's 50
plus 35 so yeah I think that's about as
simple as I can write it if you wanted
or express it as a decimal you could
approximate it by putting this into a
calculator and however precise you want
your approximation to be but that over
here that's the length of this line our
hypotenuse in our right triangle but
more importantly for the question
they're asking the distance between
those points